they are loud and ready to protest
against the g20 summit this group has
just arrived from Switzerland to join
the hundreds of other enter g20
activists who are already here a local
park has become makeshift camp to
organize demonstrations but setting up a
tent here wasn't easy to camp or not to
camp that question kept a lot of people
in Hamburg busy the city of Hamburg the
top court of Germany that said comes
like this one are of course permitted as
a right to assembly but the police at
fearing violence these camps must go
leading to a crackdown now in the latest
decision the Administrative Court of
Hamburg said overnight camping is
permitted that's possible in two parks
in Hamburg this activist is happy about
the temporary camp gear cos the court
decision may now reduce anger among
protesters and the focus can finally
shift to their goals
yeah actually very interested in talking
about why we are here to protest against
the g20 there was that crisis that
capitalism capitalism and war this man
calls for a workshop the crowd is well
networked and quickly becoming a unit
sharing meals playing music almost feels
like a modern day Woodstock but people
living nearby fear that the radical left
may mix up with the peaceful crowd you
don't know if they are going to remain
peaceful or not will they stay in the
camp or walk around the neighbourhood
the camp is about to empty for the rest
of the day the protesters are headed to
a demonstration near the harbour the
police are already there Hamburg is
bracing for the worst tonight welcome to
hell that's the name of tonight's anti
g20 demonstration and as you can see
behind me the crowd is getting bigger
and it is getting louder there both
sides the protesters and the police are
saying they are prepared prepared things
may become even Messier tonight among
the protesters are also members of the
extreme radical left we meet up with
georg again he's ready to march with the
crowd we are going to show the g20 that
then welcome here in Hamburg
so is it going to be peaceful well I
think you should to give back the
question to the police and police didn't
hesitate to react with full force
they used tear gas and water cannon to
disperse the crowd after some protesters
started throwing bottles organizers had
said they wanted to turn hamburg a city
that calls itself germany's gate to the
world into a gate to hell and that's how
it looked on the streets before the g20
summit even began
[Music]
[Applause]